Do you think that we're going to find out
that the name Black Widow is like getting
belts in karate?
Like you start out as a White Widow, and then
you're a White Widow with a yellow tip, and
then you're a Yellow Widow?
Oh. I hope so.
Nina, what are the biggest questions we want
answered in Black Widow?
So we've gotten so many tiny, tantalizing
looks at her past through flashbacks and other
movies.
I think it was Age of Ultron where we kind
of got the most look at it, where the Scarlet
Witch, or rather Wanda at the time, brought
out everybody's worst memories.
But I'm really curious to see.
We're going to get her entire backstory for
the first time, as you said, in the entire
MCU.
And I'm also really excited and have a lot
of questions about the character of Yelena,
her sister, played by Florence Pugh, because
I think she's a phenomenal actress and a great
addition to the MCU.
So I'm really curious to learn more about
Nat and also her family dynamics, her dynamic
with Yelena.
I think it's going to be really exciting.
Yeah.
So you want to learn all about the family
backstory for this character, who we've known
for over 10 years now.
Yeah.
You've got Scarlett Johannson playing her.
It seems like it's been a little bit of a
waste to have such a talented...
Someone who was nominated for two Academy
Awards in a year recently, to not be able
to play the more emotional side of Natasha.
So I think it has the potential to be a more
kind of family and relationship-centric Marvel
movie.
Yeah.
Cool.
I agree.
I think that that's a really good point, that
all we've known about her is that she was
raised in this red room and there's some program.
And we know that the plot is going to surround
this program, but we don't know much else
about her as a human being.
Right.
So I think that, yeah, I think that's a really
good bunch of questions to answer.
Yeah.
Tom, what do you think?
What are the questions you want answered in
Black Widow?
I'm also thrilled to see it.
I'm excited to get a lot of questions answered.
I want to find out what the Kessel Run is,
and how Black Widow managed to make it in
less than 12 parsecs.
It was hard to do, but she managed it somehow.
So I think that you're right.
I mean, in addition it would probably be helpful
if they explain how she came up with the name
Black Widow.
I mean, you don't just come up with a name
like that.
You don't just have a name.
No, you're going through customs and you're
like, "I'm a widow."
And they're like, "But what color?"
And then she looks at the jacket that she's
wearing.
Right.
Well, it also seems like a nickname that someone
would give to you.
Like kind of the Kill Bill, like assassin
nicknames, like Black Mamba and Rattlesnake,
like a dangerous snake.
I'm like, Black Widow doesn't sound like something
you make up for yourself.
That would be kind of lame.
Legitimate.
And that's exactly the sort of thing that
I'm curious about.
Did Black Widow's friend, Professor Xavier,
lose his hair naturally or was it during a
fight with Apocalypse?
Is Black Widow related to Ernst Stavro Blofeld?
Does it turn out that they were brothers all
along?
I'm really worried about this movie.
I'm excited for it.
I think that Scarlett Johannson has made the
character so much more interesting than I
ever thought that she was in the comics.
She's added a lot of depth to it, and so did
Joss Whedon, so did all of the writers.
But I'm very concerned about the idea of the
precedent of, we need to fill in every blank
in these stories.
That's a good point.
I can't think of a time when that's made a
story more satisfying, at least not in recent
history.
Godfather Part II.
I thought you're going to say three.
I was so excited.
Well, no, you raise a really good point there,
too, because this is probably, aside from
Captain Marvel, this is...
Well, no.
I'm already contradicting myself.
There've been a few prequels, right?
A few jumps in time.
Captain America, the First Avenger obviously
took place before Iron Man 1, 2, Thor and
Incredible Hulk.
So Captain America went back in time, but
that was for a brand new character.
So it's filling in tons of blanks, but still
telling a new story wrapped in the Marvel.
Yeah, go ahead.
Just very specifically, with Black Widow,
I think that a lot of what makes her work
is that you don't know stuff about her.
You know, I think that a lot of the intrigue
comes from the mystery.
We kind of get to imagine for ourselves with
what happened in Budapest.
Isn't that the Patton Oswalt joke, where he's
like, "I don't want to know the backstory
of my favorite characters.
I just want to like them."
Yeah.
Darth Vader's a little kid.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
I've watched a couple videos recently about
Cruella.
I haven't watched Cruella yet, because I don't-
Nor have it.
... care about how the villain from 101 Dalmatians
became a mean lady and apparently...
I'm not going to give away spoilers, in case
anyone wants to watch it, but apparently the
origin for her distaste for Dalmatians is
pretty amazing.
I've seen a clip of it and it looks insane.
It's one of those things where you don't need
to know.
You don't need to know.
And so I agree that there's definitely a danger
here with Black Widow, in terms of, I want
to see the family dynamic.
I want to know more about her and her family
and how she fits into that.
I did a little research.
It looks like, and maybe this is common knowledge,
maybe it's not, obviously we've been preoccupied
over the last year, so I haven't dived deep
into what this movie is going to have.
But apparently all the family members are
not her biological family.
Right.
These are adoptive family members.
And so it still will be interesting to learn
more, and I know that there's going to be
some flashback scenes.
I think Tom raises some good points, that
if we get too into the weeds about the details
of every in and out of this character's history,
it's going to be a little bit...
It's going to fill in too many blanks, right?
Like when they finally published Wolverine
Origin, back in the, I want to say late '90s.
Terrific point.
Yeah.
That's a bad comic book.
Sorry.
It's not good.
I don't care about seeing Wolverine as a little
kid.
I don't care.
I mean, in that same vein, sorry to disappoint,
I think Solo is a bad movie for the same reason.
Yeah.
I don't need to know why his name is Han Solo,
is my point.
I think the movie is fine, but I didn't need
to know where his name came from.
That was not something that ever kept me up
at night.
So I hope Black Widow doesn't go in one of
those directions.
I think there's ways that it can be a good
prequel and actually flesh out this really
interesting character.
But the timing is also weird, because she's
already dead.
Exactly.
In the MCU.
And that's so jarring.
I know that there was a huge delay, obviously,
because of the pandemic, but still.
But even without delay, it still would've
come out after she'd been dead for several
months.
Exactly.
So it's so weird to be like, well, this character's
back, but she's not going to be an any future
set installments.
That's very jarring.
Do you think that we're going to find out
that the name Black Widow is like getting
belts in karate?
Like you start out as a White Widow, and then
you're a White Widow with a yellow tip, and
then you're a Yellow Widow?
Oh.
I hope so.
That would be awesome.
I'm actually really-
Watch out.
She's a Brown Widow.
She's pretty good.
She's almost achieved the level of Black Widow.
How great would it be if it turned out that
this whole movie just takes place in a strip
mall in Russia, where somebody is teaching
little girls TaeKwonDo.
The Russian equivalent of Tiger Schulmann?
It's just weekends.
It says Russia, but it looks exactly like
New Jersey.
You're like, I think that's just Cherry Hill.
I've been there.
Yeah.
A Domino's guy just drove by.
What's going on?
There's a Guitar Center right in the background.
Why didn't they just get rid of that in post?
I was just going to say, Guitar-ski Center-ski.
So, one of the things that I want to see answered,
Tom brought it up.
I do want to know what happened in Budapest.
It's one of those things, those parts of her
character, just to remind everyone, we first
hear about Budapest and the first Avengers
movie.
I think they bring it up once or twice in
a couple of the other Avengers movies where-
She and Hawkeye talk about it a lot.
Right.
Black Widow says, "This reminds me of Budapest."
Hawkeye says, "You and I have very different
recollections of Budapest."
I feel like we're probably not going to get
a flashback to Budapest, but I think it would
be a nice little fill in the blank there,
to kind of give us a sense for this thing
that they've talked about.
It's iconic enough that we all are talking
about it, even though we have no idea what
happens.
And it's not in the same realm of this is
how Black Widow got her jacket.
This is how Black Widow got her weapons on
her arm.
This is how Black Widow got her haircut.
Like we don't care.
But I do think that that's a nice piece of
backstory that I would love to kind of get
filled in, personally.
That's one of the questions I'd like to see
answered, personally.
I hope we get a haircut montage.
Like the SNL Black Widow trailer?
Where they give her a make-over?
Yeah.
There you go.
That's perfect.
What if it's just a romantic comedy?
What if it feels exactly like 27 Dresses,
but it's a Marvel movie?
I would love a Marvel romantic comedy.
She's trying different catsuits on.
There's a voiceover where it's like, "Black
Widow is too busy saving the world to find
love."
Yeah.
We're going to talk about this eventually,
about She Hulk.
This is a different topic, but that's literally
one of the things I want them to do with She
Hulk, where she's a lawyer, she's a She Hulk,
where is she going to find love?
Right.
Can a woman have it all, when you're busy
saving the world and trying to establish a
successful law practice?
A question as old as time itself.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I basically want Liz Lemon as She Hulk.
And instead of running a variety show, she's
doing a superhero themed law practice.
I love it.
In a lot of ways, the giant sky portal above
New York is like another character in the
show, which is really great.
Yes, exactly.
Perfect.
So yeah, those are all the things I definitely
think...
I think we all agree here that as far as questions
are concerned, we want answers to questions.
We want to know more about this character,
but we don't want to know everything.
And I think one of the things that I can say
with confidence is that with Black Widow,
it's a Marvel Studios movie.
We don't have to worry that they're going
to shoe horn in an origin story for every
element of her character.
With Solo, right?
You brought up Solo not being a great movie,
and I think that most people would probably
agree.
There's a lot about it that works.
There's a lot about it that maybe doesn't
quite work.
And I think that a lot of that has to do with
the fact that the production had to basically
change hands midway through.
They weren't sure what they were doing when
they first started.
The studio wanted this, the filmmakers wanted
that.
Then they bring in Ron Howard and then they
do all these re-shoots.
Right.
I mean, that movie had a lot of \troubled
production issues.
And Black Widow, also, the anticipation is
so high because we've been waiting so long.
We were supposed to see this movie over a
year ago.
Yeah.
And even that was way too long.
Exactly.
Right.
I think it'll be pretty cool.
Yeah.
I agree.
I'm excited to see it.
Who's Taskmaster?
What's happening with Taskmaster?
I want to know that part.
That part I'm excited about.
Yeah.
So before we sign off on this one, let's talk
about that.
One of our coworkers at Looper, Sarah, who
works in the scripts department, she was talking
with the rest of the team, and I believe she
was the one who brought up the idea that,
potential spoiler alert, She predicts that
it's going to be Rachel Weisz's character.
Of course, it's going to be Rachel Weisz's
character.
Okay.
Do we all pretty much think that this is what's
happening?
Are we children?
I'm sorry, I thought that we were having an
adult conversation.
If it's not Rachel Weisz's character, I will
walk out of my own living room or wherever
I watch this film.
I mean, that's the thing, right?
It's the same thing with who is the Power
Broker, right?
It's like, if it's not Sharon Carter, who
else is left?
It has to be someone who hasn't been shown
in this.
And so far we know it's not David Harbour.
He doesn't fit in that suit.
It's probably not Florence Pugh, because they're
probably getting her ready to be the next
Black Widow.
I've got a little Yelena Funko Pop behind
me, actually.
They're already marketing her as a new superhero.
There you go.
Black Widow 2.
And so then you've got Rachel Weisz's character
who is the mother figure.
Yeah.
And what better storyline is there for the
mother figure to betray her children, right?
Naturally.
Like we've all gone through.
Sure.
We've all fought our mother in the same way.
That's a classic story.
It's so relatable.
Yeah.
That's what I like most about this idea, is
how relatable it is.
That's why I watch Marvel movies, is for the
relate-ability.
So I guess that's the better question then,
since we're all pretty much on board with
this being the reveal, I guess we hope that
the reveal is handled in a revealing and exciting
way.
Yeah.
I hope it's not quite as clumsy as some of
the things that we found lacking in Falcon
and Winter Soldier's kind of bigger reveal.
So I'm hoping Cate Shortland, the director,
who is kind of like an indie director...
I just looked her up and I'm not familiar
with a ton of her work.
So I'm curious to see kind of how she handles
this story and this very likely reveal.
I mean, I guess I hope it's not her, because
it seems like the obvious choice, but I don't
know who else it could be.
Maybe it'll be some other character that we're
introduced to that we are not even aware of,
and it'll be some super big, awesome, secret
surprise.
That would be great.
I would love that.
Yeah.
I think it was really brave that they decided
to go with an indie director, especially after
Crystal Skull sucked so bad.
You did it.
You did it, Tom.
We got to freeze frame him like Breakfast
Club style.
Thanks for joining us.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single new episode.